let's go to Casey from Kansas Casey from
Kansas you're next today what's on your
mind can you hear me hear me yes I can
okay and I think social murder would be
a better word for what Trump did there
social murder rather than genocide
interesting okay
but uh
back to my question I guess please
recently the Joe Biden and Eric Adams
you know how they've pivoted on crime
kind of like the 90s tough on crime era
coming back again I know Eric Adams did
did Trump as well I'm not a well I'm
sorry did Biden as well I'm not aware of
that what did Biden do
well you know how he blocked the recent
DC Bill and he's been you know kind of
like going to the right a bit on crime
pretty much trying to
set himself apart I guess from
progressives and other Democrats who
haven't focused on it as much okay yeah
I'll I'll concede a little bit I'll
concede that at least for the purposes
of your question
okay
but uh
from my perspective at least from the
midterms it seems to me that the
Democrats like fetterman who didn't
Focus as much on crime that they didn't
lose their elections
but the Democrats in New York who
kind of fear-mongered over it I feel
like they kind of campaigned against
themselves in a way by kind of giving in
to like the Republican narrative on
crime themselves that's interesting I
think there's anything to that I think
there I'd need to look a little more at
the numbers and the specific races
you're talking about but I do think that
there's a risk to the focusing on crime
aspect to a campaign which is if the
people you're talking to
don't actually believe that there is a
crime problem wherever it is that they
are it can absolutely backfire and one
of the things that we have determined
is that if you zoom out the violent
crime rate in the United States has been
declining for a very long time yes there
were some spikes in some places over the
last three years at different times but
The Narrative of the dangerous blue
States and blue cities is certainly not
true at the state level you see higher
rates of crime in red States even within
cities for all the talk about New York
City the crime rate and violent crime
rate in Oklahoma city is higher and so I
think the risk which you're astutely
pointing out is if it doesn't resonate
with people if people are sort of like
yeah you know I feel very safe and
they're not talking about anything else
I'm not going to vote for them that is a
real backfire that can happen
it's another thing for me too because
even if people don't feel safe where
they are because they're you know
listening to 24 7 media that's worried
about crime
who are voters going to go for are they
going to go for the Democrat that is
doing tough on crime light right or are
they going to go for the Republican
that's tough on crime you know Ultra or
something right so you're saying either
way it's better for whoever is going
hardcore on the crime stuff
well I I don't think it's good for
Democrats at all it's not good for
Democrats either way perspective I think
that you're on to something I think that
you're on to something I think we can
probably try to verify this empirically
I don't have the data in front of me but
yeah I think that you're absolutely on
to something Casey
do you think it's a good strategy for
Biden in 2024 to focus on crime or I
don't think no I will so listen Biden's
not focused on crime I agree he's
talking more about it than maybe we
expected or we might expect or you know
might think he would I don't think he's
talking about it so much that it's
really going to be uh detrimental in the
way that you're talking about
okay
well that's all I got thank you all
right thank you so much very much
appreciate the call there's Casey from
Kansas